Let's analyze a
one-dimensional collision,
where we're in the
laboratory reference frame.
And we have V1 initial
and V2 initial is 0.
It's a frictionless surface.
But there's a collision here.
And now we're going to make this
collision totally inelastic.
Now what that means is that the
two particles stick together.
So if this is our
initial state--
and let's, again, choose
a direction i hat-- then
our final state will just stick
those two particles together.
And they're going to move.
We only need one velocity
for the final state, i hat.
Now again, let's assume that
there's no external forces.
There are clearly
internal forces
that are acting between the
two particles as they collide.
But, remember, we know
that internal forces
cancel in pairs.
And if there's no
external forces,
the momentum of the
system is constant.
So we can write down our
momentum condition very simply.
And we'll write it again
in terms of components.
We have some incoming
momentum into the system.
And all of that incoming
momentum is going out.
And now, is energy constant?
Well, a totally
inelastic collision,
energy cannot be constant.
And the reason is that
these internal forces
will cause deformations
that are irreversible.
So the objects
might be deformed,
which is a loss of-- some
of that kinetic energy will
go into deformation.
There could be noise.
There could be heat generated in
the collision, lots of sources.
When objects stick together,
kinetic energy is not constant.
In fact, we can even figure out
the change in kinetic energy,
because we can see here that Vx
final is m1 over m1 plus m2 V1
x initial.
And now let's ask ourselves, in
a totally inelastic collision
what is the change in
the kinetic energy?
So our final kinetic energy
is 1/2 m1 plus m2 V-- here,
we can, again, right in terms
of components-- Vx final,
because the component's squared.
That's no problem.
And we just have this initial
kinetic energy coming in.
Now we have a solution
for our problems.
So let's just put that in.
m1 plus m2 times m1
over m1 plus m2 times V1
x initial squared minus 1/2
m1 V1 x initial squared.
And now let's pull
out the 1/2 m1
V1 x initial squared--
1/2 one factor of m1 V1 x
initial squared.
But what we're left with
here is another factor of m1.
And downstairs, we
have an m1 plus m2
outside but an m1 plus m2.
Now remember, we
didn't square that.
We have an m1 plus m2 inside.
So there's that m1
plus m2 minus 1.
Now this is the
initial kinetic energy.
And when we subtract
these terms,
we have negative
m2 over m1 plus m2.
And so what we see
here is-- I'm just
going to rewrite this again--
that the kinetic energy,
the change in
kinetic energy, just
depends on the initial kinetic
energy and this mass ratio.
In fact, if we asked
ourselves, what
is the ratio of that
loss of kinetic energy
to the initial kinetic
energy, that just
depends on the mass
ratio of our two objects.
In particular, it
should be a minus sign,
because the kinetic
energy is decreasing.
And so this is the fact that
it's very transparent now
that in a totally
inelastic collision
the kinetic energy
is not constant.
Where did that energy go?
It went into other
forms of energy.